a new white supremacist terror attack
targets jews in san diego
the new york times reveals its full
anti-semitic bias and the media rushed
to defend
ilhan omar i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show all right we got a lot
to get to today none of it particularly
happy news unfortunately it was a
a pretty brutal weekend for the country
we'll get to all that in just a second
first in 2008 the u.s national debt was
10 trillion dollars today the debt is
nearly 22 trillion dollars it is rising
like a hockey stick
if you do not think that we are sitting
on a house of cards you're living with
your head in the sand but
since you're listening to my podcast
you're smarter than the average bearer
so what is your plan
can you afford another hit to your
retirement like the last downturn when
the s p dropped 50 percent
it's worthwhile to hedge at least a
little bit against inflation and
uncertainty
and instability with precious metals
gold is a safe haven against uncertainty
my savings plan is diversified yours
should be as well the company i trust
with precious metal purchases
is birch gold group and right now thanks
to a little-known irs tax law you can
even move that ira or eligible 401k into
an ira backed by physical gold and
silver which is perfect
for people who may want to protect their
hard-earned retirement savings from any
future geopolitical uncertainty
look back historically when the bottom
falls out of everything else gold does
tend to safeguard savings
birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five star
reviews and a plus rating from the
better business bureau contact birch
gold group right now
get a free information kit on physical
precious metals see if diversifying into
gold and silver makes sense for you
this comprehensive 16 page kit reveals
how gold and silver can protect your
savings to get that no cost no
obligation kit
text ben to 47 47 47 that is ben
to 47 47 47 again text ben
to 47 47 47 so over
the weekend on shabbat on saturday it
was the last day
of passover and on the last day of
passover
a white supremacist gunman entered a
shoal
entered a synagogue chabad in poway
which is
about 45 minutes north of san diego
i know that it's close to san diego
because i was actually staying in san
diego for the holidays so i was
relatively close to this happening
the gunman entered the synagogue on
saturday he was yelling anti-semitic
slurs
and then he opened fire with an ar-15
style gun says the new york times we
still don't know whether it was an
actual ar-15 or if it was merely
a semi-automatic rifle he apparently
paused when the rabbi of the
congregation tried to talk to him but
then he fired again and he shot the
rabbi
in the hand twice apparently he shot him
in both hands the rabbi has lost one of
his finger
his attack left a 60 year old woman dead
the rabbi wounds in a 34 year old man
and a girl with shrapnel wounds this was
of course the
last day as i mentioned of passover
this was obviously a hate crime the
gunman was identified as a 19 year old
resident
of san diego he did leave another one of
these terrible manifestos
as i say i'm not going to mention the
name of the shooter on the show because
i don't mention the name of mass
shooters on shows because i don't want
to give them publicity
nor am i going to read his manifesto on
air suffice it to say it is a typical
white supremacist screed
about the replacement of european
peoples by jews
it also suggests that it's just hatred
of president trump i mean there's
there's a good deal in there
about how president trump at least
several lines in there about how
president trump is a pawn
of the jews a tool of the jews
apparently this
this manifesto was posted early on
8-chan 8-chan is the even more
neo-nazi anti-semitic version of 4chan
4chan
is sort of a lot of trolls some of whom
have alt-right ties
8-chan is like the worst of the worst
and
this and his manifesto sounds a lot like
the other manifesto from the guy in
christchurch the piece of crap in
christchurch new zealand
who shot up the mosque president trump
offered his sympathies from washington
he said our entire nation mourns the
loss of life praise for the wounded
stands in solidarity
with the jewish community we forcefully
condemn the evil of anti-semitism and
hate
which must be defeated here was
president trump
responding to the attack in poway our
entire nation mourns the loss of life
prays for the wounded and stands
in solidarity with the jewish community
we forcefully condemn the evil of
anti-semitism and hate
which must be defeated just happened
and president trump has spoken out
routinely against anti-semitism for for
all of the talk about president trump
going soft
on the alt-right at charlottesville some
of which i think is true his initial
statement for example he did not condemn
white supremacy or the alt-right at
charlottesville and then in his
follow-up statement
he condemned neo-nazism he condemned
white supremacy by name but he also
suggested that there were people at the
white supremacist march who were good
people very fine people on both sides
that was the controversy over that
statement
his entire remarks for the record on
that and this will become
relevant when we discuss in a second the
ramifications
of this attack in the left's attacks on
trump you know president trump's full
statement
when it came to the should the
charlottesville situation which has been
become
sort of the point of the spear for the
attacks by the left on president trump
when it comes to anti-semitic
attacks president trump said all of
those people i've condemned neo-nazis
i've condemned many different groups
not all of those people were neo-nazis
believe me not all of those people were
white supremacists by any stretch
those people were also there because
they wanted to protest the taking down
of a statue
robert e lee he said i think there's
blame on both sides you look at both
sides i think there's blame
objectively on both sides i have no
doubt about it you don't have to doubt
about it either
if you reported it accurately you would
say that the neo-nazis started this
thing they showed up in charlottesville
excuse me they didn't put themselves
down as neo-nazis you had some very bad
people in that group you also had some
very fine people on both sides you had
people in that group excuse me excuse me
i saw the same pictures as you did
you had people in that group that were
there to protest the taking down of to
them
a very very important statue and the
renaming of a park from robert e lee to
another name
and then he continued by saying you had
people and i'm not talking about the
neo-nazis and the white nationalists
they should be condemned totally
you had many people in that group other
than neo-nazis and white nationalists
the press has treated them absolutely
unfairly now in the other group you also
had some fine people but you had trouble
makers and you see them come with the
black outfits and the helmets and the
baseball bats
you had a lot of bad people in the other
group too so to give the full context of
what president trump was saying
he did in fact condemn neo-nazism he
didn't in fact condem white nationalism
he also sort of made up this other group
of people who were there at the protest
who were very fine people and that's why
people said he was being soft on the
alt-right because the only people there
were all writers in any case president
trump every time there's been an
anti-semitic attack has condemned it by
name
he has condemned it by name now the
rabbi at this
at this congregation is wrapped in a
israel goldstein for people who don't
know the chabad movement the khabad
movement which is an acronym for
mabina and all of which are aspects
of knowing god is wisdom is
understanding and
knowledge so the chabad movement is is a
very spiritual movement
it was driven by the true rebbe for many
years they
the the chabad movement is well known
for going to
basically random places all over the
world to provide outreach to jews who
are in those parts of the world
it is the most front-facing part of
jewish orthodoxy
i have a lot of friends in the kabab
movement i know many of the rabbis in
the khabad movement most of the top
people in the kabab movement
every place i go chabad is there i used
to joke that
if if people if jews were to land on the
moon then chabad would already be there
i mean
is everywhere and they are very
front-facing they are extraordinarily
welcoming
and they do a great job of bringing in
diverse groups of people
the fact that they are very good at
doing outreach and bringing in diverse
groups of people might be why more
people are alive today as opposed to
debt
in power here's rabbi israel goldstein
speaking from the hospital about what
happened
shalom rabbi israel goldstein
here from khabada poway it's not even 24
hours
since the unthinkable unfathomable
terrorist attack occurred at khabarov
i'm encouraging and i'm pleading with
every single jew that sees this appeal
this weekend go to your own prospective
synagogues
fill up the ballrooms fill up the
sanctuaries let them see that nothing
will take us down
and we all need to stand together hold
hands together love each other just like
the rebbe taurus unconditional love
that a little bit of light pushes away
darkness
okay and this guy has to be shot by this
anti-semite and and he was not the
person who has killed the person
obviously who was killed
was a 60 year old woman who apparently
was shot pretty much
straight away uh there were there were
reports also that she had pushed herself
in front of the rabbis that the rabbi
would not be shot
those at this point i believe are more
rumor than confirmed
in any case here is israel goldstein
speaking further from the pawai khabad
the day after the shooting and you can
see his hands are bandaged because he
lost a finger in this attack
yesterday this horrific terrible event
that has occurred here
in my own interpretation lori took the
bullet for all of us
she died to protect all of us she didn't
deserve to die
she's such a kind sweethearted just a
good human being
she didn't deserve to die right in front
of my eyes
i was the last one to see her and to be
with her
but i do know that this is lori this is
her legacy
and her legacy will continue okay so it
is also worth noting here that
attendance at the synagogue was slightly
larger than usual because of the holiday
many of the older congregants were there
because of yizkuriz
is a memorial prayer that the jews do on
the last day of passover and so a lot of
the older congregants were there
specifically to say yizkur for relatives
who had passed away
one of the people who was there was a
guy named oscar
stewart oscar stewart is a is a border
patrol agent
who has recently rediscovered his jewish
roots this is what cloud is great for
and he had spent three and a half hours
apparently every saturday driving all
the way to poway
from the border so that he could pray at
the synagogue
and apparently when he heard the shots
ring out his training from his years in
the military kicked in
he said i yelled as loud as i could in
my mean sergeant voice i yelled get down
and then i ran
toward him he said that the gunman then
fled because he was a coward and
the meanwhile they were there the rabbi
ran into a room
where a bunch of kids were stationed and
he told everybody to get out
one of the people who picked up there
there are a bunch of people there
one of the people who was there was a 34
year old israeli
who was actually coming from state road
steroid is the town in israel that has
been under significant rocket fire from
hamas so he moved from
anti-semitic attacks in israel from
hamas to anti-semitic attacks and power
from a white supremacist
he picked up his niece and he started to
run he was wounded his eight-year-old
niece was wounded
as well so here is the eight-year-old
niece explaining what exactly
happened so you got hit with shrapnel
yeah little pieces no like anyone is
pretty big
but these are little pieces so
you look so this was like a pretty big
piece
and then it went back here so the piece
of shrapnel went in your leg and then
came out the other side
what were you thinking then did it hurt
um
in the first place when it was like
gushing blood i didn't even feel it
and then after like they wiped it and
then like the blood was off and it was
like
it it felt like i had the giantess
bruise ever okay this would be
eight-year-old
dahan and her uncle is almond perez who
was the guy who who picked her up and
ran
with her in a second i'm going to
explain why it was deeply important that
this border patrol agent
was there and why once again a good guy
with a gun is the only person who is
capable of stopping a bad guy with a gun
when something
like this happens first after a
childhood full of unsuccessful attempts
to pull the wool over mom's eyes do you
really think she won't be able to tell
the difference between
a last-minute mother's day gift and
something truly thoughtful this mother's
day
don't settle for anything less than the
biggest and brightest bouquets from
1-800 flowers.com right now
1-800 flowers has great deals for mom
like 24 assorted roses for 24 bucks
that's only a buck per rose so
over the last week my wife actually
passed
her board so she's done with her boards
now and so i was
as i mentioned in san diego and i used
1-800 flowers to have flowers delivered
to her that's how great 1-800 flowers is
they did it moments notice it's really
fantastic
all of their flowers are just beautiful
with a bright and beautiful mix of
orange yellow and pink blooms these
assorted roses are guaranteed to make
your mom smile or your wife smell or
anybody else smile
assorted roses are the perfect way to
surprise all of the moms in your life
wife sister grandma
roses from 1-800 flowers are picked at
their peak from premier farms they're
shipped overnight to ensure freshness
24 assorted roses for 24 bucks it's an
amazing offer but you have to hurry
because it expires on friday
trust 1 800 flowers to make mom feel
loved this mother's day order today from
1800 flowers.com
again to order those 24 stunning
assorted roses for 24 bucks go to 1 800
flowers dot com
shapiro that's 1 800 flowers dot com
shapiro order today
save at 1 800 flowers dot com shapiro
the offer expires
on friday okay so the guy who was the
off-duty police officer
off-duty u.s customs and border patrol
agent was named jonathan morales
he was among the worshipers and he had
been asked by the rabbi
to bring his gun to services because
jews all across the united states
are understanding that there is a
significant threat
in my synagogue there are many armed
people at my synagogue we have security
guards at my synagogue this is true for
every synagogue in my area
that's because jews across the country
understand that there is a threat
of terror both from radical muslims and
from white supremacists as well
well this this particular the rabbi said
that morales recently
rediscovered his jewish roots he would
travel three and a half hours from el
centro
to pray with us at our shul he felt this
was his house of worship and many times
i said jonathan
you worked for the border patrol please
arm yourself when you are here we never
know
when we'll need it well this would have
been the time that they needed it and
thank god that the guy was there and
thank god that he was armed because he
was there because he was armed the
shooter's gun jammed
and then the combat veteran who came
charging
and then there there were two combat
veterans i guess there was one named
oscar stewart
who was charging at him and yelling at
him
he said get down and then he said you mf
i'm gonna kill you
and he started he just he didn't this is
not the guy who had the gun apparently
he was an iraq combat veteran and he
just ran directly at the guy without a
gun
he said i knew i had to be within five
feet of this guy so his rifle couldn't
get to me
i ran immediately toward him i yelled as
loud as i could he was scared i scared
the hell out of him
also there was another guy a border
patrol agent named jonathan morales
and jonathan morales had a gun so thank
god combat veteran thank god for combat
veterans and thank god also
for people who are armed in places of
worship
so that's you know
when people say it's time to disarm
civilians
as though that's going to protect other
civilians it's
foolishness now in a second i'll explain
what exactly
has been happening on places like 8chan
so 8chan is the is the place where these
shooters have basically been
congregating we're seeing an increase in
the number of these attacks one of the
reasons we're seeing that increase
is because it used to be that the
world's worst human beings were located
in sort of disparate areas of the
country with no people cheering them on
these online forums these online forums
they create
an echo chamber where people feel like
they are playing to a crowd of people
who will be cheering
for them robert evans has a piece over
at bellingcat.com talking about 8-chan
and it is worthwhile discussing it for
just a second
he says on april 27 2019 at around 11 30
a.m local time a young man with a
semi-automatic rifle walked into the
chabad of poway synagogue in power
california
he opened fire killing one worshiper
wounding three others in the hour since
the shooting a manifesto believed to be
written by that shooter began
circulating online
evidence has also surfaced that like the
christchurch mosque shooter this killer
began his rampage with the post on
8chan's
politics board although both of these
attacks may seem different since they
targeted worshipers of different faiths
both shooters were united by the same
fascist ideology
they were also radicalized in the same
place 8chan's politics board
this has been corroborated by posts on
the board itself where anons as the
posters call themselves to be anonymous
posters
recirculated the shooter's since deleted
post
in it the alleged shooter claims to have
been lurking on the site for a year and
a half
he includes a live a link to a live
stream of his rampage with
thankfully does not appear to have
worked he also included a pastebin link
to his manifesto
the very first response to his
announcement was another anonymous
person cheering him on
and telling him to get the high score
aka kill a huge number
of people this shooter's manifesto is
also filled with bleep posting which are
internet in jokes meant to distract
authorities in the media
and make eight chance politics boards
seem less threatening and more jokey
the fact that this is the second
politics border related shooting in the
house of worship
in slightly more than a month should be
enough to explain that this is false
hn apparently is a large website
includes a number of different
discussion boards about everything from
animated left-wing politics
politics is one particularly active
board on the website it is best
described as a gathering place for
extremely online
neo-nazis the overarching goal of
politics held by most of its members
is to radicalize their fellow anons to
real-life effort posting i.e acts of
violence in the physical world
this goal is well embodied by a post i
found in a discussion of the poway
synagogue shooting
in which there's a picture of a person
kind of walking around looking like a
doofus before politics and after
politics
board there's a there's a picture of a
shooter
in black gear with a rifle this writer
says i've browsed the politics board on
an almost daily basis since the
christchurch shooting
it has not been difficult to find calls
for violence on monday march 15th
march 25th of this year i ran across
evidence of anons translating the
christchurch shooter's manifesto into
other languages
in an attempt to inspire more shootings
across the globe
the tactic can work today's shooting is
proof the poway synagogue shooter
directly cited the christchurch shooter
as his inspiration
saying he decided to carry out his
attack roughly two weeks after
that shooting many of the anons referred
to the christ church shooter as a saint
complete with medieval inspired
iconography
as i say there's no way to shut down
free speech but
if the authorities are not monitoring
8chan for this sort of stuff i don't
know what the hell they're doing
people in the know have known this stuff
for long before
christchurch happened i was being
harassed by people on 4chan and hn for
for years before any of this stuff
happened obviously it's one of the
reasons i have full-time security
the fact that these the the fact that
people have only gone to pick up on this
now is is obviously quite disturbing
it's also true that the internet can be
a place where
the worst of us congregate the internet
can be a great place for spreading of
information it can be a wonderful place
for spreading of charitable
do-gooderism it can be a wonderful place
for exchange of ideas and for prevention
of monopolies on ideas
but it can also be a place where
terrible terrible people can find
other like-minded terrible terrible
people to
cheer them on when they do these awful
things so it's worth noting
that there are these places online where
these folks congregate and
these folks sometimes their evil speech
turns into evil action
now as i say that does not mean that you
can
in any good conscience shut down free
speech in the united states to stop
this sort of stuff but you certainly
have to have the authorities aware when
people are making violent threats
and violent imprecations there are
people on our staff who in the last
several months have been targeted
so i'm i'm very well aware of all of
this i've been aware of this for years
and i think that the police
are and should be aware of this on an
increasing basis meanwhile
the media reacted to the poway synagogue
shooting by blaming president trump
as you knew they would uh it is really
horrific and awful that they would do so
it is horrific and awful for a couple of
reasons first of all president trump has
been quite strong on anti-semitism
he has all of his statements on
anti-semitism have been far more blunt
and far more purposeful than anything
democrats have been saying about
anti-semitism for years that's because
democrats have been protecting
anti-semites inside their own party
republicans have not now president trump
as i criticized him for at the time
was terrible with regard to the
alt-right in 2015 2016.
go back and listen to my episodes after
charlottesville go back and listen to my
episodes during the 2016 election cycle
he went and nodded at people he thought
was being nice to him we're being nice
to him and that was a terrible terrible
thing to do
but when it comes to anti-semitism
president trump has spoken out
repeatedly against anti-semitism i
guarantee you
that everyone virtually everyone who is
in the show that was just shot up was a
president trump voter
this is an orthodox community i
guarantee that everyone that shalhabad
chabad tends to be extremely pro-trump
okay then so the idea that trump is
responsible for this especially because
in the manifesto itself
this person explicitly derides trump as
a tool of the jews
trump is not behind this now trump
may have contributed to the alt-right
gaining increased credibility in
2015-2016
maybe into early 2017. that has not held
true since then
that was bad that has not held true
since then
so to blame president trump for all of
this is just absurdism of the highest
order
and yet what you've seen is the media
doing exactly that here's the cnn panel
saying they didn't believe president
trump when president trump condemns
anti-semitism even
despite the fact that president trump
has jewish grandchildren despite the
fact that president trump is the most
pro-israel president
in the history of the united states
despite the fact that president trump
has forcefully spoken out against
anti-semitism
repeatedly and condemned it from other
people still the media pretend
that president trump is responsible for
this here's the cnn panel saying they
don't believe trump
on one hand you want to give the
president his due
but when you consider the language that
we have been discussing over the last
couple of days especially with joe biden
getting
getting into the race what the president
has said making excuses revisionist
history
about what happened in charlottesville
and on and on one has to wonder
as a thinking rational person
if he means those words and if they
ring hollow to americans who have been
looking for him
to say those things and stay the course
as angela has said
instead of trafficking in big bigotry
and racism and anti-semitism and hate
and making excuses for us okay so again
this is the media overreading and
overreading
for a particular political purpose in a
second i will show you how they've been
doing this
routinely and then i will get to the
media themselves and who exactly is
promoting anti-semitism
throughout the united states if you're
not going to call it out everywhere then
you shouldn't be
then you can't be trusted to call it out
anywhere okay we'll get to that in just
a second first vitamins and supplements
can be kind of confusing
persona takes the guesswork out of it
one of our employees here at the daily
wire jared he takes persona vitamins in
the morning and in the evening he filled
out their online assessment he indicated
he wanted the vegetarian formula
some of the personalized supplements in
his order include green tea extract for
energy support digestive enzymes as part
of the happy gut formula
the packaging it comes in is sleek
simple and innovative there are separate
packs for each morning and each evening
so you know exactly what you need to
take each and every day here's how you
can get started
take a three to five minute assessment
and find out exactly what you need and
then you get recommendations based on
your goals lifestyle
allergies special diets and prescription
meds convenient vitamin packets are
delivered to your door
each month persona only uses the highest
form of ingredients that are easiest for
the body to absorb including cultural
the number one pharmacist recommended
probiotic
ingredients are tested when they arrive
at the manufacture they're tested again
before they are shipped to make sure
they contain
the right amount of ingredients you can
certainly find cheaper vitamins but
you'd have to pay 30
more to get the same quality in a
bottled vitamin persona checks for over
850 medications against their database
of supplements
they recommend to ensure no negative
interaction persona offers over 90
different supplements which creates 5
trillion possible combinations
to personalize your recommendations
specifically for you someone on my team
uses persona jared loves it you will too
right now
whether you want to sleep better have
more energy or simply stay as young as
you can
my listeners can go to
personanutrition.com
ben that's nutrition
p-e-r-s-o-n-a-nutrition
com shapiro and get 50 off your order
today that's persona nutrition dot com
slash shapiro it's five minutes that can
change your health right now persona
nutrition dot com
shapiro really takes just a second and
you can make your health a lot better go
check it out right now so
the media's response to poway is
naturally to do two things blame trump
and blame guns
shocker they're always gonna blame guns
even though a gun probably stops this
attack
from being significantly worse and
they're gonna blame trump because it
fits in with their
general thesis which is that all hatred
can be relegated to one side of the
political aisle it can all be relegated
to president trump that is a politically
convenient answer
that is obviously not correct if
president trump is not an anti-semite
at the best thing you can say about
president trump if you're on the left
the most damaging thing you can say
about president trump if you're on the
left
is that president trump winked and
nodded at the alt-right in 2015
2016-2017
that was really bad again i was there
condemning it that is
not what happened here what happened
here is that this
shooter and white supremacists
everywhere are more likely to believe
that president trump is a tool of the
jews that he is too philosomatic
rather than that he is cheering on their
anti-semitism and yet the media are
trotting out
this lie that trump is somehow
responsible for the poway synagogue
shooting
despite the fact that nobody at poway
synagogue nobody in the orthodox
community actually thinks this
here is joe scarborough mouthing these
words
we are so far beyond dog whistles here
donald
we are so far beyond dog whistles the
blood
the blood that is spilled is on your
hands
from white nationalists from people that
listen to that sort of rhetoric
any violence to journalists enemy of the
people
you were just inciting violence
it's just it's just obvious you were
unfit to be president of the united
states
okay so he's going to need to cite what
exactly trump did
that was responsible for this shooting
they keep saying things like trump is
inciting violence so according to joe
scarborough trump incited violence
with what exactly with what ex like what
did he do to incite violence
again i condemned all of his comments
surrounding charlottesville and with
regard to the kkk in 2016.
and with regard to steve like i
condemned all that stuff i continue to
condemn all that stuff
trump hasn't done that stuff at least in
the last couple of years
and he's been extraordinarily
phylocemetic in both practice
and policy so what exactly is joe
scarborough talking about
and yet the media continued to trot this
stuff out not just the media members of
the democratic party so you see for
example
waleed shaheed who is an adviser to
bernie sanders and who happens to be a
member of the justice democrats blaming
trump for all of this despite the fact
that as we will see in a second
the democratic party has been
significantly promoting anti-semitism
openly and so have the media for a while
here
i mean amongst my jewish friends amongst
people pouring out on social media i
think people just felt really sick to
their stomach
about this attack and just sick to their
stomach about the way that the president
continues to be unable to respond in the
kind of way the leader of the country
should be able to respond
the conspiracy theories cited by these
neo-nazis in pittsburgh and new zealand
and now outside san diego are
all really they all say the same thing
which is that
this crazy story about how somehow jews
are letting in immigrants into this
country which is
you know similar to what republicans ran
on in 2018 saying that george soros was
supporting and funding the migrant
caravan conspiracy theory that trump
never
condemned and actually uh seemed to
support um when asked about it
okay that again this is just it's just
amazing so you have democrats in the
media blaming president trump for a
shooting that doesn't have to do
with president trump at the exact same
time at the exact same time the members
of the media
who are condemning this sort of stuff
where are their words
for the anti-semitism of the democratic
party here's the thing if you're going
to call out anti-semitism it is actually
incumbent on you to call it out whenever
you see it it is incumbent on you to
call it out on all sides just as you
would call out racism
on all sides if for you anti-semitism is
merely a way to club ilhan omar
but you don't really care about it when
it comes from white supremacists or if
alternatively anti-semitism is a way to
condemn white supremacists but you don't
care about it when it comes from ilhan
omar or it's a way to condemn trump but
you don't care about it when it comes
from the radical left
then i don't trust you on anti-semitism
and neither should anyone else
i'm not going to trust the new york
times's take on president trump and
anti-semitism when they are printing
cartoons like this so thursday
right a day and a half or friday the day
before it was friday i believe
the day before the shooting happened at
poway the new york times international
edition
printed this cartoon of president trump
and benjamin netanyahu for those who
can't see
the cartoon is viciously disturb or
anti-semitic i mean it is straight from
the pages of nazi newspapers
straight from those pages it is a
picture of benjamin netanyahu
his face pasted onto that of a wiener
dog with a jewish star
hanging from his collar and president
trump being led around
like a blind man by bibi as a dog
president trump wear fat wearing aquipa
and wearing black glasses because he's
being led
on a leash by bibi netanyahu the jewish
dog
with the jewish star hanging from his
collar this was printed in the new york
times international edition now a lot of
people have been saying well people are
on the right they're very upset about
the cartoon
why aren't they upset about the shooting
i am upset about both
here is something to note these
shootings these shootings have been
occurring on a sporadic basis against
jews my entire lifetime i can name a
dozen of them off the top of my head
including some in my own community there
was one at the west valley jcc
back when i was a kid in 1999 i believe
it was
okay there was there have been attempted
killings of jews in my city
more more relevant recently
obviously it is a different thing for
mainstream american publications to
print
full-on nazi cartoons the mainstreaming
of anti-semitism on the left is not
the same as the mainstreaming of the
anti-semitism on the right so what the
left is trying to say is that president
trump has mainstreamed anti-semitism
because he went and nodded at the
alt-right from 2015 through 2017.
okay he did not mainstream anti-semitism
among republicans which is why
78 of republicans say they are
sympathetic to the state of israel
it's why republicans by and large are
far more phylocemetic than the far left
is
it's why republicans have been
condemning ilhan omar
the new york times is a is the linchpin
of democratic media
of left-leaning media in the united
states it is the mainstream newspaper in
the united states and in their
international edition they are printing
cartoons that are straight
from the pages of their sturmer they are
printing cartoons that are straight from
the pages of the nazi-esque palestinian
newspapers i mean these are nazi
cartoons and they're printing those
so am i upset about that yeah because it
speaks to the mainstreaming of
anti-semitism
inside the left now in a second i will
show you how the new york times they
apologized but i'll show you in a second
how the new york times should have known
better and then the new york times
printed another anti-semitic cartoon
today
another one it's amazing like
you know why because the anti-zionism
and extreme leftism
of the people on the left have allowed
them to mainstream anti-semitism in a
pretty vicious way we'll get to that in
just a second first
let's talk about making your
neighborhood safer rings mission is to
make neighborhoods safer you might
already know about their smart video
doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere
ring helps you stay connected to your
home anywhere in the world so if there's
a package delivery or a surprise visitor
you'll get an alert you'll be able to
see here and speak to them all from your
phone
that's thanks to their hd video and
two-way audio features on ring devices
i have ring.com at my house i have a
ring device at my house
and i've been working on bringing a
building a ring of security kit as a
listener you have a special offer on a
ring starter kit available right now
with a video doorbell and motion
activated flood like cam
the starter kit has everything you need
to start building that ring of security
around your home too as
you can tell i take security
extraordinarily seriously
you should too just go to ring.com that
is ring.com for special savings
ring.com make your home safe you can see
unfortunately
a lot of time you think your house is
safe it may not be safe and it is
perfectly true
that a lot of criminals will ring your
doorbell see if you are home before they
decide to rob your home
ring.com allows you to prevent all of
that go check them out right now
ring.com
ben that is ring.com ben okay in just a
second
we'll get to the new york times and it's
anti-semitism the mainstreaming of
anti-semitism
what are the three types of
anti-semitism and how are they being
mainstreamed
in the various areas of philosophy and
and ideology around the world we'll get
to that in a second first you're going
to have to go over to dailywire.com and
subscribe when you do you get the rest
of this show
live you also will get two hours of this
show this afternoon i'm back on my full
schedule it means two hours of me
this afternoon we'll have special guests
we'll have insights it'll be great
and you'll be able to ask us questions
during the breaks so if you want to
correspond with me
that's the way to do it you got to be a
subscriber to do all of that we have all
sorts of
sunday specials that are coming up that
will be available on saturday for you
you will be able to
correspond with other hosts at the daily
wire you'll be able to take
advantage of our backstage we have all
sorts of brand new awesome stuff coming
for subscribers
go check it out right now and for 99 a
year you get this
the very greatest in beverage vessels
the leftist year is hotter cold tumbler
go check it out right now that leftist
tears
hot or cold tumbler will make your life
significantly better also subscribe to
youtube
subscribe to itunes last month we were
the second most listened to podcast on
planet earth so make sure that we are
number one
this month go help us out over at
youtube and itunes leave us a review it
always helps we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
okay so what you're seeing from the
media as i say is an attempt to blame
president trump for all of this now let
me backtrack for a second there are
three types of anti-semitism that are
deeply worrisome in today's day and age
type of anti-semitism number one white
supremacist anti-semitism this is what
you are seeing
in at the shul in poway it is also
manifest in a more generalized white
supremacist ideology
that ends with shootings at mosques for
example in christchurch the same person
who committed the shooting in poway
apparently tried to burn down a mosque
in the last several weeks
in in california as well so white
supremacist ideology totally evil now
has that been mainstreamed inside the
right the left would like to suggest
that it has i see no serious evidence
that it has
every mainstream republican not only
condemns this stuff but outright hates
it
when people speak about this stuff in a
positive way
they lose their committee assignments
this would be steve king see if king has
lost every committee assignment
his primary opponent kevin feinstra whom
you should give to
has been raising much much more money
than steve king
republicans are not mainstreaming this
stuff now
then there's left-wing anti-semitism
left-wing anti-semitism
is papered over with a thin veneer of
anti-zionism basically
left-wing anti-semitism says that
because there are winners and losers in
society
and winners have inherently exploited
the losers jews are too successful
and therefore jews can be held
responsible for inequality
in society this crosses paths with
islamic anti-semitism which also
suggests that jews are too successful
and jews are manipulating world events
then the words of ilhanom are
israel has hypnotized the world or it's
jewish money behind american support for
israel that conspiratorial mindset
meets paths with the intersectional left
now which is being more mainstreamed
white supremacy by the mainstream right
or ilhan omar type anti-semitism by the
mainstream left
radical islamic anti-semitism is a
serious threat to jews in israel as i
mentioned
one of the people who was shot at poway
is from state road so he spends every
day having rockets fired at him from the
gaza strip by jew haters
in the gaza strip and then he comes to
the united states and he gets shot at by
a white supremacist
all types of anti-semitism are dangerous
not all types are equally dangerous
in in every place and not all types are
equally well accepted by mainstream
outlets so white supremacy is not a
mainstream philosophy in the united
states
it is not a what it just isn't
statistically speaking
it is extremely dangerous they're the
people i'm most worried about being shot
by
they they're very very dangerous they're
a small subgroup of people
who are awful and who do violent
terrible things but as far as being
mainstreamed as an ideology there is no
question that left-wing anti-semitism
which starts off as oh yeah we're just
criticizing israel and quickly morphs
into
no israel is an exploiter israel is an
apartheid state the only reason people
support israel is because of the
nefarious power of the jews
we don't have to comment on
anti-semitism against jews because they
are not intersectionally
put upon that left-wing anti-semitism
has become extraordinarily prominent
which is why
you have the new york times printing
stuff from nazi newspapers in the
international edition
it's not like they didn't know who this
cartoonist was his old cartoons are just
as anti-semitic
here's an old cartoon showing a it's a
take-off
of the warsaw ghetto it's it's it's
holocaust memorial week this week i
believe
this is a picture from the warsaw ghetto
uprising a very famous picture uh
not even from the uprising of jews being
herded onto trains being held up by
nazis
except that this anti-semitic artist has
put kathias
on all of the jews and made all of the
nazis into israeli soldiers with
a jewish star helmet right so this guy's
an anti-semite and the international
edition just printed it
the new york times apologizes for all of
this they said we are deeply sorry for
the publication of an anti-semitic
political cartoon last thursday
in the print edition of the new york
times that circulates outside of the
united states we are committed to making
sure nothing like this happens again
such imagery is always dangerous and at
a time when anti-semitism is on the rise
worldwide
it's all the more unacceptable we've
investigated how this happened and
learned that because of a faulty process
a single editor working without adequate
oversight downloaded the syndicated
cartoon and made the decision to include
it on the opinion page
so as one guy we're looking into it
we'll stop it we're sorry
no this is in this is deeper and more
indicative of how the new york times
operates it's an anti-semitic newspaper
it's a newspaper that it's in its news
coverage has openly admitted it did not
cover hate crimes against jews in new
york city because it was not
intersectional enough
brett stevens writes a piece in the new
york times this is the new york times
attempt
to to back track and and paper over
its in its own anti-semitism they let
brett stevens write
there they say the cartoon appeared in
the prince version of the international
edition
the cartoon itself was selected and seen
by just one mid-level editor right
before the paper went to press
supposedly
they say the paper's position is that it
is guilty of a serious script but not a
cardinal sin
not quite brett stephen says the problem
with the cartoon isn't that its
publication was a willful act of
anti-semitism
it wasn't the problem is that its
publication was an astonishing act of
ignorance of anti-semitism
and that at a publication that is
otherwise hyper alert to nearly every
conceivable expression of prejudice from
mansplaining to racial microaggressions
to transphobia
imagine if the dog on the leash hadn't
been the israeli prime minister but a
person of color such as
john lewis or a muslim like ilhan omar
would that have gone unnoticed by the
wire
service and this raises a question says
brett stevens how have even the most
blatant expressions of anti-semitism
become almost undetectable to editors
who think it's part of their job
to stand up to bigotry the reason is the
almost torrential criticism of israel
and the mainstreaming of anti-zionism
including by this paper which has become
so common that people have been
desensitized to its
inherent bigotry so long as anti-semitic
arguments or images
are framed however speciously as
commentary about israel there will be a
tendency to view them as a form of
political opinion not ethnic prejudice
but anti-zionism is all but
indistinguishable but from anti-semitism
and practice and often an intent however
much progressives tried to deny this
that is obviously true which is why the
new york times can apologize for that
and then within the next two days print
this cartoon this cartoon is a cartoon
of benjamin netanyahu descending from a
mountain
ala moses holding a selfie stick and
holding behind him
a tablet with the flag of the state of
israel what the hell is that supposed to
be
well it turns out that the original
cartoon was sanitized from the new york
times
the original cartoon is supposed to be
bibi
walking down the mountain holding the
tablets followed by donning
donald trump holding the other tablet so
in other words it's the same thing
bibi the nefarious jews leading donald
trump by the nose so
in other words the same people on the
left who think it's fine to print that
sort of crap
and say that bibi is leading trump by
the nose a jew is leading trump by the
nose will say
that trump is anti-semitic and
responsible for this that's their hot
take
that's their hot take and then we're
supposed to take them seriously very
seriously we'll get to the
the political left's reaction to this
particularly ohana marks it's very
telling
hey so bernie sanders you just saw
waleed shaheed blame president trump for
what happened in poway here is bernie
sanders tweet
about the synagogue shooting he says
another horrific shooting at a place of
worship today at the poway synagogue in
san diego county we must work every day
to eradicate all forms of hatred and
bigotry and take serious action to
protect americans from gun violence
now quick note the original critique of
president trump's take on
charlottesville
is that he did not condemn white
supremacy by name where is the
condemnation of anti-semitism by name
where this reminds me very much of after
the
christian the attacks on christians in
sri lanka when democrats
simply refused to say that it was an
islamic a radical islamic attack on
christians which it was
democrats it simply chalked it up to
generalized hate and democrats have been
doing this with anti-semitism and
anti-christian
sentiment for quite a while now every
time there is something bad that happens
to a jew
the first reaction is well let's condemn
all forms of hate this is how they shied
away from condemning ilhan omar who's an
open anti-semite
instead they just said we hate all forms
all forms of hate are bad white
supremacy particularly bad
how about this white supremacy is evil
people who propagate white supremacy are
evil
left-wing anti-semitism is evil people
who propagate it
are evil islamic anti-semitism is evil
people who propagate it are evil
why is it hard to say any of these
things and you see this even from
peter beinart who's honestly as close to
a hamas spokesperson as anybody on the
left
i mean every time israel gets in a war
with hamas it's always israel's fault
binary it's just awful in every way so
he tweets this out he tweets
if you foam and hatred against muslims
don't offer your sympathy when hatred
kills jews
okay so let's let's parse that for just
a second if you foment hatred against
muslims
don't offer your sympathy when hatred
kills jews muslims and jews are two
separate groups
and just because the same people
sometimes are interested in killing both
muslims and jews
that does not make the groups exactly
the same now you shouldn't foment hatred
against muslims
but the the in the the innate swing
from peter beinart away from
anti-semitism and toward we must protect
ilhan omar is amazing because that's
what's happening there right what peter
binary is doing there
his tweet is obviously a way to protect
ilhan omar
so if you say ohana mars an anti-semite
peter beinart says aha you're attacking
johan umar that means you don't care
about dead jews
how sick is that logic how sick is that
logic
and if you condemn what happened in
christ church then presumably
that's not enough if you say that
radical islam is evil
and that normal islam might be fine
or that you know many muslims who are
good or that islam isn't inherently tied
to violence but there are too many
muslims who are violent peter binary
will condemn you
for the killing of jews and power he
says anti-semitism and islamophobia are
two symptoms of the same white
nationalist disease
you either fight them both or you are
complicit in them both well how about
you
fight white supremacy overall but also
you're allowed to critic i mean this
it's so funny the same people who will
say that if you talk about anti-semitism
you're trying to silence talk about
israel the same people will say well if
you criticize
radical islam at all really you're in
favor of white supremacy
what a joke peter bainard is just
intellectually
corrupt beyond all measure so ilhan omar
then sounds off herself
says my heart is breaking after today's
deadly shooting at chabad congregation
in san diego
on the last day of passover and six
months to the day after the tree of life
shooting we as a nation must confront
the terrifying rise of religious hate
and violence
love trumps hate so that that last line
there obviously a reference to president
trump
and a suggestion that because that was a
slogan that was being used against trump
in 2016.
now listen do i think that ilhan omar is
happy when jews get shot at
no i don't but ilhan omar certainly does
not take
anti-semitism seriously she clearly does
not i mean she is an anti-semite she
does not take anti-semitism seriously
and then hilariously enough ted cruz
tweets out the anti-semitic left he's
condemning the new york times cartoon he
says the anti-semitic left
whether ilhan or mars repeated
anti-israel slurs or the new york times
apologizing for hamas terrorists and
running racist cartoons is getting worse
and the house can't even pass an
anti-semitism resolution responsible
dems need to say enough is enough ill
hanomar tweets back to that a white
nationalist literally terrorized a
synagogue during passover yesterday and
you have yet to say anything
shame on you yes i'm sure that ilhan
omar is the leading tip of the
spear in fighting anti-semitism and
white nationalism when it targets jews
i'll fight white nationalists over any
of this crap i don't think that ilhan
omar
is leading the leading the fight against
anti-semitism in the united states and
that suggestion is a joke
it's a joke uh i'll just point out here
one final thing about el hanomar
so over the weekend she accused
president trump of incitement again
incitement again why because president
trump pointed out that
ralph northam had said in an open
interview that there are situations in
which a baby is born
and then doctors and the mother can
decide whether it should die or not and
ilhan omar said this is truly dangerous
and sickening is this deranged president
suggesting parents and doctors are
working together to commit infanticide
we have seen religious fanatics bombing
clinics and threatening women
this will fan the flames of violence
stop the misinformation so in other
words according to ilhan omar it's
incitement if you criticize her
it's incitement if president trump
points out what ralph northam the
governor of virginia said but ilhan omar
is never guilty of incitement no matter
how much anti-semitic bile she spews
as i said before if you are blind to
anti-semitism
from one particular side of the aisle
because it favors your political
position
you are not in the fight against
anti-semitism you're part of the problem
if anti-semitism is just another
political club to be wielded
if ilhan omar is given the credibility
to speak out against anti-semitism
while routinely engaging in
anti-semitism
she has a lot of the same opinions about
jews that the white supremacists had in
that manifesto
in that manifesto the base the the white
the the shooter basically says
effectively says about jews that they
control the world media that they
control the way money runs that they
control
opinion about israel am i going to take
her for am
i going to take her at her word that she
hates anti-semitism
again i'm not going to equate her with
the shooter because i don't think
they're the same i think that people who
commit violence are not the same as
people who say evil things but am i
going to take her condemnation of
anti-semitism seriously no
i'm not no i'm not i'm not going to take
the condemnation
from the new york times seriously and
i'm not going to take it seriously from
a press that covers for the new york
times
either call it all out or i'm not going
to believe you
it really is that simple okay in just a
second we'll get some things that i like
and then we'll get to some things
that i hate so things that i like today
so there's a
great essay by theodore herzl
the founder of zionism zionism is a good
thing guys it is a good thing that there
is a jewish state
it is a good thing that the jews have a
place that they can go for protection
considering
that in the wide history of humanity
jews have not been left alone very often
there's a great piece published in 1897
about jewish identity by theodore herzl
who is not a religious jew
talking about the need for people to
respond to anti-semitism by re-engaging
with their root
i totally you know i think that's a
beautiful idea
it's worth reading the essay he talks
about how
a secular jew becomes more religious in
response to people targeting him
he talks about the holiday of hanukkah
and the radiance shining forth from the
menorah
he says first one candle it is still
dark and then the solitary light looks
gloomy
and it finds a companion then another
and yet another the darkness must
retreat
the young and the poor are the first to
see the light then the others join in
all who love justice truth liberty
progress humanity and beauty when all
the candles are ablaze everyone must
stop in amazement and rejoice in what
has been wrought
and no office is more blessed than that
of a servant
of light so you can read the writings of
theodore herzl they're well worth
reading for all the folks on the left
who condem
zionism and suggest that the state of
israel shouldn't exist and that hamas is
in the right
and then condemn anti-semitism when it
results in a white supremacist shooting
someone in poway
i'm going to take that with a little bit
of a grain of salt guys just a little
bit of a grain of salt okay
time for some things that i hate
alrighty so things that i hate today so
aoc spent her weekend alexander
ocasio-cortez spent her weekend
along with the other justice democrats
speaking out about the hot issues of our
time
one of them aoc says she doesn't care if
you are an undocumented person in the
united states i'm glad she doesn't care
it seems like we should probably care
since we don't know who these folks are
and they're not paying taxes and some of
them are drawing on social services
that does not suggest that the vast
majority of illegal immigrants are bad
people
i don't think that i know illegal
immigrants i don't think that they are
bad people i think the vast majority of
them are coming here to work and make a
living
but i do care about their legal status
if you are a citizen of the united
states you should care about the legal
status of people who are here
aoc says no no no i don't care about any
of that
first of all i believe in human rights i
don't care
i don't care i don't care if you're
documented
i don't care if you're undocumented i
don't care if you're out here
i don't care if you're in rikers i
believe in your fundamental human rights
fundamental human rights okay and then
she
proceeds to define that as voting for
example
hey well there's a great piece at the
new york times by great i mean absolute
garbage
from a guy named david bentley heart a
scholar of religion and a cultural
critic according to the new york times
he has a piece called can we please
relax about socialism
and then he talks about how socialism is
really not bad
he says to be trapped in the boarding
area of a smallish airport in the upper
midwest
is as often as not to be subjected to
that be shielded of fricatives gutturals
plosives and shrieks of hysterical alarm
that constitutes political discussion on
fox news pouring incessantly from those
obnoxious
pendulous ceiling televisions so this
guy
is a terrible writer by the way and then
he says that fate i avoided a few weeks
back instead there i was with the
commentator ben stein hovering over me
like some grim heathen god exuding all
the effervescent charm
of a despondent tree sloth glumly
wobbling his jowls and opining that
representative alexandra ocasio-cortez
espouses a political philosophy that in
the past led to the rise of hitler and
stalin
it's true about stalin and then he says
i realize this has become axiomatic on
america's excitable right i know that in
this country we employ terms like
socialism
with wanton in different historical
details and i'm painfully aware here's
the part where it gets good
i am painfully aware that the male fox
commentariat
nurtures its sickly obsession with miss
ocasio-cortez partly because they resent
her cleverness
charisma and moral vitality but mostly
because they suspect that in high school
she was one of those girls they had no
hope of getting a date with though
really she comes across as someone who
could look past the face of even the
purest sweat
suet if she thought she glimpsed a
healthy soul behind it
i mean what in the world the new york
times not only is an anti-semitic
newspaper it's a garbage newspaper
i mean my goodness to print who would
print this this trick this trickle i
mean it's just
so it's not because she's deeply
ignorant it's not because she says
stupid stuff it's not because she's on
the cover of magazines or is praised
by journalists across the left wing of
the spectrum it's not because she's
extraordinarily famous
and has a lot of power it's because
people think that they
she wouldn't have dated them in high
school and also
i mean i can't think of anybody who
wants a date with ocasio-cortez more
than david bentley heart according to
this paragraph
she comes across as someone who could
look past a face of even the purest suet
if she thought she glimpsed a healthy
soul behind it she's like mother teresa
i mean amazing amazing yes i'm sure
that's it
our media yeah i'm definitely gonna take
them seriously from now on okay final
thing
that i hate so this is the thing that i
hate slash like okay
here comes some game of thrones spoilers
guys so we're gonna do game of thrones
for like two minutes here
so last episode of game of thrones it
was
emotionally enjoyable they have they
have
i don't know why they shot it in a
through a potato so they so the entire
episode is too dark it is blotchy it is
hard to look at i was watching it on hbo
go
and i was streaming it so it was kind of
best quality my tv is pretty good
it's still very difficult to see what is
going on the battle plan makes no sense
also the thrill of game of thrones in
the first few seasons was the
fact that anyone could die at any time
which made it much more realistic
than other fantasy sagas where you knew
that your favorite characters were going
to live
here they sort of eliminated a couple of
of characters who you knew were going to
go at one point or another but they
couldn't even eliminate many of the
fringe characters who probably have no
major role going forward except to give
somebody else
you know a a a sort of happy ending in
the story
meaning like it was pretty obvious not
to get into details and i'm just
whatever if you haven't watched it tough
brienne was probably going to die here
right like you thought brienne was going
to die they knighted her
she was serbian she finally had reached
her life's conclusion and now she's
going to lead the left flank in this
climactic battle against the night king
and so figured she would die and
probably tormund would die also neither
of them dies
and neither of them dies even though
they are surrounded by ice zombies i
mean
surrounded by them grey worm you thought
for sure he's gone nope
he's still alive the only people of any
consequence who die here
at all are let me try to remember our
jorah buys it and theon those are the
only people of any serious kind
dolores ed dies also but you know who
cares
theon dies and he was destined to go a
long time ago so
like it was two people who knew were
gonna go their stories had finished
they were toast everyone else lived
everyone so every single person dies
because of the guy zombies except for
the characters you like
guys like there better be some surprises
in store or this is gonna be the most
anti-climactic final season ever now i
enjoyed it
i enjoyed arya teleporting to kill the
night king
i i mean that was fun and and i don't
agree with all the people who are
like there are people who are
idiotically saying that arya is a merry
suit no the definition of a mary sue is
rey from star wars
if you are if you are a character who
randomly has powers without any training
you're mary sue
if you are a person who trains for six
seasons to do the sort of thing you just
did
then you are not a mary sue so arya
killing the night king fine with i don't
know what brand's doing all episode
so bran's just like being a bird or
something you're sitting around being a
bird
wha why what was he doing no one knows
they're flying around in the clouds on
the dragons can't tell what's happening
at all no one can tell what's happening
so
there there's some serious holes also
battle strategy i'm gonna take this
entire massive force that we brought
across from the
across the the wide sea and we will
bring them
across the narrow sea we'll bring the
entire dothraki horde and then we will
eliminate all of them in the first five
seconds in an ill-fated pickett's charge
against a superior force in darkness
makes perfect sense also we will not to
play the dragons at that time to kill
all of the members of the night king's
army
we'll just wait until the entire
dothraki horde gets extinguished
and then we'll do it also we will
station the trebuchets in front
of the of the ravine
and we'll station all the troops in
front of the ravine so he won't actually
use the physical barrier that we have
created to protect our soldiers stop the
forces of the night king from
approaching so that we can you know
kill them on the other side of that
barrier we will instead stand in front
of the barrier
so that they can kill us and then we
will retreat haphazardly back
into winterfell also in the crips how
does no one die in the crips how is that
a thing
okay so there's my take hopefully
next week we'll finally get to cersei
again i think that's my biggest problem
with cersei as a character is i don't
think that she is
clever so i think that the build-up of
cersei and
euron greyjoy who basically is pirate
who works at zara
uh not my characterization against
stephen miller not the
trump stephen miller like stephen miller
red steez online character that's pretty
much right
how is that alliance as interesting as
the alliance against them i guess that
the entire force has been decimated but
danny still has a dragon in any case
we'll see where it goes from here i was
always more interested in the politics
than the night king they had to get rid
of the night king but
with that said there were some moments
in the show that i really liked but
why it had to be filmed so that no one
could see what was going on
the pretentious creative choice i had
heard that they said well you know
it's not realistic if you use lighting
there are dragons guys
pretty sure that realism is not top of
the line concern
i i would like to see some things like
that's okay how about like if you're
gonna spend
whatever it was some tens of millions of
dollars on an episode how about we see
the result on
like that would be good okay all right
well we will be back here a little bit
later today
two more hours of the ben shapiro show
or we'll show up here tomorrow
review all the news get into it i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
this is the ben shapiro show executive
producer jeremy boring
senior producer jonathan haye our
supervising producer is mathis glover
and our technical producer is austin
stevens edited by adam syavets audio is
mixed by mike caromina hair and makeup
is by jessua olvera production assistant
nick sheehan the ben shapiro show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2019. hey everyone
it's andrew clavin host of the andrew
clavin show
game of thrones the avengers end game a
lot of big stories are going around and
one of those stories
is that donald trump is a racist oh wait
is that a story
or is it a lie we'll take a look on the
andrew clavin show i'm andrew clavin